bonjour madame rivière hariri je suis
conseillère départementale
et du délégué aux sports de pleine
nature et activités de plein air je suis
aussi membre de la commission permanente
et je suis maman de trois enfants avec
mes enfants mon mari notamment une
famille de cinq enfants et j'ai 37 ans
infirmière libérale sur sainte marie
depuis maintenant une dizaine d'années
c'est une commune qu'en fond
j'ai hâte achats
une note particulière parce que c'est
une ville de coeur d'adoption parce que
je suis originaire de saint paul et
c'est une ville et que j'ai appris à
connaître et à apprivoiser de par mon
métier d'infirmière et dont je suis
tombé tout simplement amoureuse
[Musique]
quand je mets si on doit l'image et je
vous dirais que nous avons dans mon cas
une jambe sociale de par ma fonction
d'infirmières libérales
avec une approche
de proximité très forte puisque
j'interviens au domicile de mes patients
et donc j'ai une réelle
j'ai un réel contact avec la population
et des éventuels besoins donc j'ai ce
volet social et cette jambe sociale je
dirais et de l'autre côté une jambe
sportif puisque passionnés de travailler
avec mon mari nous avons ouvert donc
aussi un club
qui va aujourd'hui
j'ai tenu au sein du département à avoir
ce côté social pour ce côté sportif pour
justement apporter donc cette touche
personnelle qui me tient forcément à
coeur mais qui reste en lien avec la
santé puisque nous savons tous que le
sport est aussi un moteur pour pont sur
pour le bien-être et pourrait pour la
santé pour tous
[Musique]
mention spéciale dame qui pour apprendre
à apprivoiser
donc c'est aussi une grosse machine avec
une capacité
financière et administrative qui permet
de pallier à différents besoins de la
part de la population des réunionnais
donc que ce soit dans les domaines des
personnes vulnérables
du sport de la culture de l'insertion
d'économies il est vrai que nous avons
plusieurs volets voir beaucoup et je
pense qu'on a une action qui peut être
très complète et qui peuvent réellement
répondre aux besoins des réunionnais il
est aussi important de
de concevoir 7,7 cette mandature et
cette nouvelle politique qui s'est mise
en place en 2021 et pour jusqu'à
2027 sur une réelle volonté de
travailler
dans un concert le territoire et non
plus deux
de centraliser sur notre canton sur
notre commune
avec des
des politiques qui ont des façons de
penser que des opinions qui sont
vraiment différents aujourd'hui on est
dans une volonté avec de nombreux jeunes
et des vues à vouloir tout simplement
avancer ensemble pour une
meilleure gouvernance et une meilleure
politique pour répondre aussi aux
besoins de la population